10 reasons you should go all in on
YouTube right now whether you want to
start a side hustle whether you're a
business owner whether you're a speaker
coach course creator and you want to
build your personal brand and generate
more leads and customers and sales or
whether you just want to launch a hobby
and express your creativity I really
believe that right now is the best time
to go all in on YouTube and actually in
this two-part series on the podcast
we're going to be talking about the
first five reasons to go all in on
YouTube which are actually internal
benefits now stick around until the end
because really nobody talks about these
and this is actually why starting a
YouTube channel will actually transform
your life it's a big promise but your
life will be transformed for the better
because of starting a YouTube channel
and then in part two we're going to talk
about the second five benefits which are
actually external benefits and we're
going to be talking about how starting a
YouTube channel will grow your income
your business and impact your world so
let's jump into number one
the first reason you should start a
YouTube channel is to become a Creator
and not just a consumer one of the ways
I like to measure success in my life is
to judge each day not by what I consume
but by what I create and there's
something so powerful that happens in
your personal life when you step off the
sidelines and you actually get into the
game I want to ask you a question
imagine a world where you actually
created more than you consume maybe kind
of tough because maybe right now you
consume some YouTube I know I do you
consume some Instagram you know you
scroll on Tick Tock maybe you're
watching some Netflix or some Hulu maybe
you're finishing up Better Call Saul the
final you know season and final episodes
right maybe you're you're consuming in a
gaming context and their majority of
humans are actually in the consumer
category now listen I'm a consumer I
like to purchase things I like to watch
things I like to be entertained I like
to be educated but something dynamically
changes when you become a Creator and
not just a consumer and imagine if you
set a goal of creating more than you
consumed of getting off the sidelines
where a lot of times the armchair
critics like to critique those that are
actually playing the game and to get
into the game yourself when you start to
create that's where the action is the
goal is to press in where most people
procrastinate have you been sitting on
the sidelines have you been just afraid
to jump out of just watching the think
media podcast or listening to it on
Spotify or apple have you just been
watching other creators watching other
business owners watching other peers in
your space consuming what everybody else
is doing but you haven't pressed record
yourself friend it's time to become a
Creator and here's what's interesting is
actually too much consumption is
actually a negative multiple Studies
have actually be found that there's a
strong link between heavy social media
consumption and an increased risk of
depression
anxiety loneliness self-harm and even
Suicidal Thoughts in fact social media
May promote negative experiences such as
inadequacy about your life or your
appearance wow so that's the plight of
the consumer in the extreme case but now
listen to this
if you find yourself growing weary and
anxious about the future scientific
research indicates that regardless of
your artistic experience or your talent
just a 45-minute session of focused
creative activity
significantly lowers your cortisol
levels in your body and thus reduces
your overall stress friend being a
Creator is where your power is when you
get off the sidelines and you start
creating you start to get more
self-confidence you start to get
momentum you actually reduce stress your
cortisol levels go lower when you
express your creativity and you punch
fear in the face and press record I want
to encourage you one of the reasons to
go all in on YouTube is to join the
Creator economy is to join this world of
being an action taker a builder a design
trainer not just a talker but a doer and
one of the reasons I love this is
because God our creator designed Us in
His image to be creative so ultimately
we are most like our creator when we are
being fruitful when we're multiplying
when we're in the game when we're
creating not just consuming number two
one of the reasons to go all in on
YouTube and remember these are internal
benefits we're going to get into yes you
could get views and all that kind of
stuff but this is some of that inner
game that really can transform your life
the second reason is history and Legacy
you know I actually surveyed some people
in our community and I asked why did you
start a YouTube channel here's what Mom
life said she said we started out to
document random and funny
uh cute things that my kids did when
they were babies but over time we got
more into vlogging so it turned into
something their Channel got some
momentum they started actually bringing
some structure to it but it started out
just as documenting life documenting
their children Danny hollenback said
this to build a video library Legacy for
my two daughters to have as a
remembrance of who their dad is and of
what I love to do
so I think one reason everybody should
start a YouTube channel is to document
their life their experience their
knowledge their wisdom and actually to
put some of their legacy and their
history on tape remember this isn't
necessarily for others people this isn't
because it'll get big this is for the
next generation one of the things that
gives me a lot of confidence is that
should today be my very last day
I am grateful that my sons have an
archive of their dad with some of my
ideas my thoughts who I was in fact with
as many videos as I've created they
really could get to know me and actually
have quite an experience with their dad
if I was God forbid to pass away at this
very moment and I'm actually
intentionally building this and I have
so much bubbling within me I have so
much I want to share in regards to my
vision my values lessons like 10 things
I want my son to know this is some
different videos that I want to create I
actually am reminded of my cousin who
actually sat down and interviewed many
of our family members and many of his
his parents his aunts his uncles friend
have you thought about starting a
YouTube channel for the history and
Legacy aspect there's something about
becoming a Creator there's something
about starting to just put history out
there put your journey out there put
your transformation out there the person
who's just consuming they don't have
that archive the person who's pressing
record has an archive a legacy that's on
YouTube number three is express your
creativity to express your creativity
forget getting subscribers like let's
get those too forget making money let's
do that also but what about just
expressing your creativity what about
just actually relaxing a little bit take
a deep breath let's chill out a little
bit we're all trying to get big we're
all trying to go viral we're all trying
to you know build our businesses and I'm
into all of that stuff but there's
something about also just slowing down
and enjoying the process there's
something about just being a maker just
actually putting in some hard work and
having something to show for it at the
end of the day jevin said this I started
YouTube as a place to have a creative
Outlet away from my clients
so even as a videographer he was doing
client work for other people but he also
wanted just a place to express himself
YouTube can be a creative outlet and a
place where you experiment share you
have fun and you let your creativity
expand
again there how do we trick the
algorithm how do we please the algorithm
how do we please the audience those are
legitimate questions how do we get
videos to go viral what's working right
now on YouTube I mean that's what this
podcast is about but there's a whole
other side of this and remember these
are the five inner reasons to go all in
on YouTube because there's just
something powerful about expressing your
creativity about maybe just
experimenting a little bit listen
experimenting with one video that's
maybe slightly off brand or not fully on
in your Niche like it might just be for
you post the video that's not going to
kill your channel it might just be
something that allows you to express
your creativity number four personal
growth I believe that one of the most
powerful reasons you should go all in on
YouTube
is because it is a great way to
accelerate your personal growth you see
starting a YouTube channel is going to
push you out of your comfort zone
it's really going to challenge you to
learn new skills it's going to build
your confidence it's going to force you
to expand your knowledge it's going to
require you to embrace continuous
problem solving it's going to develop
your resilience I have learned that
starting a YouTube channel is one of the
greatest personal development tools that
I believe exists in the modern era why
because you're really your own Media
Company you're really actually starting
a business even as a solo creator that
might be just be doing a hobby because
what are you doing you gotta you gotta
Market your channel you're trying to
uploading a thumbnail is like uploading
a graphic image
it's the it's the visual to promote a
video trying to title your video you're
trying to learn how to write titles
you're trying to learn how to
communicate on camera and edit you're
you're you have to bring such a
multiplicity of skills and then
eventually you're thinking about maybe I
can monetize this you're trying to think
about negotiation how do I negotiate
with Brands maybe you're trying to hire
somebody now you're actually building
out a team so you're a manager of others
you know even if you just hire a VA
through vid shops or you know a virtual
assistant type of an editor you're
running a media company even if it's
just small and if it's just you you're
wearing multiple hats what that does is
it forces you to grow is it easy no can
it be painful absolutely but life is
about growth
when we sit still we actually lose
ground but when we press into our future
and we challenge ourselves and learn new
skills one of the best ways to challenge
yourself to grow is again to stop
consuming to start creating and you're
just going to see a lot of growth and
it's not going to be without pressure
like you might feel like quitting you
might feel like it's heavy you might
feel overwhelmed you might feel like
there's a lot to learn and that's all
true but friend remember pressure
creates diamonds
the personal growth you will experience
will benefit your life and here's what I
want to say because of course you know
check out part two and we're going to
get into all kinds of other benefits but
listen if your YouTube channel never
blows up but you become a Creator you
can have more confidence because of that
if your YouTube channel never even goes
to the moon and you never have a million
subscribers but you have a history and
Legacy and memories that you can share
with your family and the Next Generation
there's something powerful about that if
you're expressing your creativity and
you're growing personally it changes you
this is why I'm so convinced that
everyone should start a YouTube channel
because you will be a better person if
you embrace the pain and and the
challenge of creating content putting it
out there learning the lessons you'll
bet you'll be a better employee at the
next place you work you'll be a better
leader at your next job you'll be a
better entrepreneur and the next thing
you start because YouTube forces growth
if you stay committed and you start a
channel
and number five build a portfolio you
know your video library ultimately
becomes an archive of your story
of your knowledge of your work I now am
12 years into this maybe even longer
because I started a channel for my
church in 2007 we did a vlog for the
pastor I started doing different videos
for the church these video announcements
that's still on YouTube there's still
that original 2007 Channel there so I
can look back at that and see part of
the journey I can look back at the 2009
content that I put out there for my
business called clearvision media
and I could see that portfolio of some
of my work and then of course today my
channels my YouTube channels are a
portfolio of my work but there's
something powerful about having a
portfolio whenever somebody applies at
think media for certain positions it's
super funny someone's like hey I'd love
to be a graphic designer at think media
we just ask them one question show it
send us your portfolio like show us your
work now listen you may not you might
not even go all in on YouTube but maybe
you're a public speaker show us your
portfolio like where's the videos of you
speaking you know if you're a graphic
designer show us a portfolio maybe some
tutorials but also that shows what
you're capable of if you're somebody who
works in HR you could have a YouTube
channel sharing your HR tips and then
when you apply someplace you're like hey
here's some of this content I've taught
we're like wow we got a portfolio of
your thought leadership of your
expertise of your knowledge of who you
are of your core values of what you
believe and then of course if you are a
videographer or something else you
you've got a portfolio if you're doing
airbnbs in real estate you're
documenting the Journey on YouTube we're
saying oh there's your portfolio of the
Empire you're building in real estate
there's just something powerful about
having a portfolio having a place where
you're documenting your work you don't
have to just be a creative you could be
just documenting with a janky smartphone
a little selfie stick and just kind of
documenting your professional life it
could be documenting your artistic
drawing life your music life there's
something about having a portfolio and I
know personally I am proud of my
portfolio
as I've built it up every upload that
has gone into that bucket into that
portfolio actually just continues to
compound my confidence and so when I
think about these first five things
these are internal
truths and results of what happens when
you commit to starting a YouTube channel
so friend have you started yet
have you punched fear in the face yet
have you been on the fence and actually
just wondering if you should go all in
in part two we're going to talk about
other benefits and really the external
benefits of starting a YouTube channel
but I would argue these internal
benefits are almost more important life
is not so much about the destination
that we're going to reach one day but
it's about the journey and these are
Journey Reasons I'm becoming a Creator
I'm expressing my creativity I'm I'm
building Legacy I'm building a portfolio
I'm ex you know I'm I'm sharing my
journey I'm growing personally that is a
transformative experience it's not a
moment in time one of the things we've
been talking about here at think media
is that creating content is not a
one-time event it's a lifestyle that
starting a YouTube channel is not just a
place where you just post one video and
ignore it it's a habit it's a routine
and it is a habit and a routine in a
lifestyle that can be incredibly
powerful to help you express your
creativity grow pork personally build a
portfolio create Legacy and ultimately
become a Creator and not just a consumer